citizens of the reject nation how is
your day going today but first john how
are you i'm good are you excited to talk
about the the dwayne see you i like to
call them more excited i love that
hierarchy boy the djcu so guys if you go
online and if you see people talking
about dwayne johnson regarding the dc
universe it seems to be a bit of vitriol
going on there and i decided to look
into it i was like well this guy does
wield more power over the dc universe
than i even realized i always just
thought it was kind of a joke some
things for sure are being blown out of
proportion and honestly i think not
everything that i'm hearing is actually
a bad thing despite the fact that it
does seem like he has actually a lot
more power over the direction of the
future than uh i even fathom but before
we go into that i want to thank
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
more on that in a little bit
[Music]
so uh to kick this off what we're gonna
talk about is you know that whole thing
that was going around online this week
about him uh writing himself out of
shazam basically and then wanting to
cross over with the mcu and how
determined he seems about it and then
some other things as well so yeah the
first thing that happened that really
struck me as odd was the fact that i
have not seen dc league of super have
you seen dc leadership professional
scene league of super pets i would like
us to react to the movie on the channel
and i followed dwayne johnson on social
media and he straight up spoiled the
post credit scene
on instagram i was like wow this guy can
just do that apparently all right
it was the weekend it came out and he
straight up revealed i don't want to
show a photo of it in case you guys
happen to miss it but even i was
surprised and uh like i would like to
elaborate more on that but i'm just not
going to due to the fact that it is a
major spoiler and a major indicator of
things he was intentionally avoiding
talking about at comic-con so that's
kind of a clue of what we're referring
to secondly uh the main thing that was
going around was about black adam and
shazam what ended up happening was this
this quote was getting taken out of
proportion because there's so much more
to the story than what people were
saying like the quote tweet was
basically like we can't make a movie
like this we would be doing black adam
an incredible disservice so everyone was
just going through it being like oh my
god why would you do this dwayne johnson
the shazam's arch nemesis is black adam
this should happen but if you read
further into the article the main reason
he made a push to have black adam not be
in it is because the movies he wanted
are two tonally different characters and
he felt it would be ultimately more
rewarding if they had stand-alone films
first that eventually led to them
crossing paths
which to me sounds way better than
trying to introduce and set up two
characters who have extremely similar
powers except one's really dark and evil
and the other one's a lot more
lighthearted and fun right and a great
way to play into the subsequent 10-year
plan thing that dc is trying to do now
you know it works really well towards
that plus you avoid that mcu initial
pitfall of like oh it's just the hero
versus an evil version of himself with
the same powers because when thinking
about the fact that they have like a
full black atom movie right now and
seeing what the tone for that is and
then looking at shazam which had such a
family vibe to it it seems like the
villain they got savannah for that was
just much more perfectly suited for the
specific story they wanted to tell and
honestly i am more excited at the
thought of black adam and shazam
fighting each other now due to the fact
that they have solo films however the
thing that seems a little bit odd is at
the same time while that was going out
it doesn't seem like the rock is that
interested in black adam fighting shazam
it seems like it's all about getting to
him fighting superman at the end of the
day yeah
so this new article came out and uh
there are some quotes i really do want
to dive into here and this is what it
was like wow he really is very
intimately involved in the future
whereas a lot of the time with these
actors they're kind of just going by
whatever's being told to them and
they're going with the flow versus he's
really involved in the universe building
and what they want to do with that a he
was able to get himself out of shazam
and a lot of people thought that that
wasn't the right call but he's been very
very patient it's been a long time that
this black adam move has been developed
so he's been wanting to make it right
and now this other stuff is doing with
universe building uh before that word
from our sponsor thank you to
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
being the cinematic artisans we
obviously are we are always in search of
ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
well thank you storybox for working with
us uh it's been an absolute pleasure so
as going back to dwayne johnson here
what he was saying is the goal is to
really expand the universe and introduce
new characters and spin off and be
really strategic about the plan we have
a few ideas of what characters people
are really going to respond to in black
adam and we're already thinking ahead to
let's start thinking about that movie
and what that movie looks like for them
and then dwayne brock johnson went on a
stage more while pushing for more dc
integration that he wants to take on the
heroes over at marvel he said i am
optimistic just my nature is optimistic
and especially when it comes to creative
especially when it comes to movies and
especially when it comes to the pantheon
of dc superheroes and super villains
across the street we have the pantheon
of superheroes and super villains of
marvel to me they cannot only exist but
they should in my mind
cross paths one
day
and when dwayne johnson sets his mind on
something i think he's determined to get
it done and we'll figure out a way to
get it done yeah that could actually
happen so weirdly as much power as this
guy has this is not a crapping on dwayne
johnson video nor is this a crapping on
dc video or anything of that sort of
warner brothers i'm under the impression
that if there's any talent out there who
makes a strong enough push to actually
get it done it's going to be dwayne the
rock john 100
it seems like they could almost be
taking notes from him in this whole
process because he's been working on
black adam through the old guard of dc
and warner brothers and now through the
new guard of dc at warner brothers he's
won a few things that seems like he's
going to endure past that point and yeah
if shazam changed so much based off a
good script and his desire to you know
expand and follow something more akin to
what marvel has been doing i feel like
them taking that advice only strengthens
the idea that one day everybody could
learn to uh put their big monetary
grievances down and yeah cross these two
universes over and you know it's like
eventually these two are going to be
less uh you know high on the status as
they are now and will need some kind of
event like that and we can only hope
that it happens in r and dwayne
johnson's lifetime and then now who's
working with zosloff and nwb alan horn
is that who it is because alan horn who
worked with kevin feige in the beginning
of building up the mcu so you have that
connection right there and i feel like
if the dc universe does manage to get on
track to really feeling like an
interconnected universe then maybe
through the cosmos of the multiverse
it's actually possible that one day it
could happen of course you'd like to
imagine and dream about such a thing but
it never seemed quite tangible and now
i'm like actually
this feels like it could actually happen
so we'll see what is in store but guys
what do you think about everything that
dwayne johnson's been talking about are
you upset that black adam was not in the
shazam movie personally i think it was
the right call
and i do i'm excited the thought of them
possibly fighting each other one day it
seems like that's in the works and also
uh the goals that he has for the future
of dc don't sound bad to me at all seems
like the right way of thinking it sounds
very collaborative and there's something
exciting about the talent of getting
involved with help because he's a
producer too and a lot of people forget
that he is a producer so yeah it sounds
like i kissed the ass dwayne johnson
this whole video
what the hell
got to guys leave your thoughts down
below you can leave a like subscribe
click that bell uh before we go let's do
a patreon
ricardo martinez you are easily the
buffest dude at the patreon and you are
the only one who i think could take on
duane the wreck jansen i think that you
should join as the you know this whole
dc hierarchy of power you need to come
in and disrupt that my dude it can't be
just the blue beetle standing up for
latinos in the mcu we need or the dceu
where's the latinos in the mcu we got
his luis come on man we need you in
these franchises so start an acting real
get into hollywood you know maybe do a
wrestling career first but parlay your
way my friend and thank you in the
meantime being here with us we love you
and we'll catch you on the next one
buddy you're the real black adam in our
hearts
[Music]